WIHATO DOH WITTS TRO'SKY AAIR
MOTHRE FA.ID
ISYO OSTF HAVE HRDEA A
YBTHOUF I YAV H'TENITEA RD
WMASAYOE U  TWIE MHEOV IHI TNK
IT0 2AS00OR ME, T MHEOVIE
FREI TDAHAT ELDWTN OS. THI
THTHTHMY THAT DS IEHARDS  ITNO
TATHERFF AAIPLOO TK EAC
BECAE USRS COFOUE ITID DND A I
SCDERIHEBE TMSIR CCU INCTAESNY M
EIBO IFAN CTYTHE T MISH
LAFRUS'SDA H DNDBA,GOIEA,IV RER
ISUNR TEFODBOUT O A IT D
LATHIMED L H TO BFFAKRE OIS H
ATREIPONTISHIT WH T.TSROKY
D.THS I AHO MET
TATTH'SHE FNESTIR O.
RTINON SHEEC THAD SO D AWIO TH
SACENAI ICE PD K ICANIUL SHO
KYTSO SERIL AHERTLE TRO T
THDOOT NO  DWELLT A E THEND OF
K. BISOO
ETHK BOO FUSOC, ESASCG MIDN INSA
ON L THEART ASYEOFS TS TRO'SKY
FEN IEX MO O,IC S3719 TO 1940.
THWILA FBASHS CKTOIV PALOT
SMEMONT INIS H ELIARERAREEAS
GYO
UNOL REVIONA, GRE
AT
OR T OORFSI RHEUSOL RANEVIOUTN
R DEOFAT C7,RE AORNDEA L
TH
NQERMED R AANY THD EN OSECOF UR
VASHUIEDIV RAL SLITAN BUT
LE
WST'TA SRTIT WH DGOIE.
ITAS TNKHATOS GO DIEIV RA,ER
NDH GAIATRE PHEERNT TKYRO TTS
ALLAEDN I MICO.
ST HINADTE ROUSKTRD OTHEINY  T
1TTBALE SUCCEEDEN L WIE DD
KYTS492 T ANDN HERONTSE T
LE.N EXI
FITH
E T RSNTWEO T TKEURY.
MOFR TTRKEURY SKY ELLNTVEUA
DVEO  T IANFRCE.19N 33
ENTH NORWAYIL UNTUN93 15 EL TITH
TIPO
LIL CAREESPRSUN  OETH
NO
N EGRWIAMEVEGORNCE FNTORITD
XPTO
KYTS.EELRO T
DWH
ATIO  M PEABYOLITALIC
SUPR
ES?RE
TH
TFIE RSF OAMHE T FSCS OUMOOW
RIOWSH TSAL TACK OOPLUGINE  ATUS
OF
1EA6,93 LOLNGDI BSEVSHIK O
LDSH
OU L SAYDIEANGNIOM CMU
SST
NTNGRI TAL T FORT MHEOS
FATIASCS RI CMEINCLINUDG
SSAS
SAN ATINIOOFNTA SLILFIM HSE
TE
AY W,EMPDAS ASSNATI ANY
ONES
PID E AGANSO ON.
STTTRSK WASOR P AAYTREDTHS E
ECMA OMIERNDOUA F GRPF O,PI SES
,RSRRSKE ANDEUAB SOT
RECTG THERR EIOPIOATNSRO FM
ABADRO.
TH
ATRI T,ALHE TOS MCOW TRIALS OF
1936 WAS TST FHEIRREF  OTHUC SH
LSTR
IA EE H ACONINVOINLVRMAG JO
TIPO
LIGUL CAFIMES RETIHEN THE
DEOTTRSKGRVSEINS AHIHE T C
T NDFEANINHE TBS ATIENA.
HASO
W WMOT RETI WEANNGO  TBE
DRITR OF SKOTY, TY  OHENLYUNCOTR
HEIN
T TOR WLDULT HAWODAK TE HIM
ESSWA MANO ICTHIT TKSO SAD RALIC
HE TWHENIDT GHTHO OUASITT  W
CRRIGTHT IN TOO, DUT BO ALS
Y IAUCLLANTHKSO  TE
TEINONESRCSIF OGO DIEIV RA EROWH
ELCAED HSEIMLFKYRO TTST,ISOR M
ON
DTETT HAIN M AENT,NDEA H
THBY TANEX MICNI CMUSTS.
EIOEC DISBYN  MICEXTOO NT GRA
ASASUMYL WOVON CTRSYER WITHIN
XIME BCOUTHEON NETSSLE IT
EDPPHAEN T AND ATSROKYNDIS H
37WIIV ARRRE TEDHEN  IYNUJAAR OF
19.
EGDIOREND A FA IDOUABTTS TROKY
EIN NALIAO  RVEHAEDESIDN I
THR BELUOU HSE TNHA AUB SBAURN
W TESI MOIC CITY.
NO IURCOSE B HTASNEE
COINEDORRPATTHNT IO EIT CY.
RARI
VEAS W A VOUALIT SERCF O
TWS FTS TORROKYND AIS HST FIR
PAORS YEANGEL SLIFF OIS H
ENS,TIINNGND AE T  AONINPOEVT
GA
TORTGINGIS HOU HSEND AEA NYRB
EL HPAISE MEYON FORKYRO TTS.
R FOOTWS;HI TNGNE O,O SPOUPRT
HOTH
OODN DEHUSOLPU AS FOINTTG
TTH
ELEAB,LSUT B AOFANO D
CR
INSIEANG INCORMPTAEON M FEYOR
TR
GU FKOTY' PIOTEROCTAYTON  P
WEDSAR, ANONAPS SOD N. O
ODI
EGREND A FA IDRABOTRO TKYTS'S
DE
SIURE INTHDEMMY WECOSIISON
GSARHEINUPEL HD LUHE T BEHOE US
IN THE SINPRG 1 OF7.93
DEH CIOMIOMSSG BEN INETH
INTNDPEENNQ IRYUIO  INTTHE
VE
CIRATH OTYF  MCOOSTRW LSIA
D SOER TCAME ARIN PLOHI
AN IBLPUICCTELNTLELUAN JOH
Y.DE
WE
DETH
LLUAY MMY WECOSIISONNT EVE
HEBY
TND EF  OSS3719 IDUE
A
ICVE
RDOFT OT NY.UI GLT
IN WTH OERDSORF O O THERAUTGE
CH
GEARDGA AROSTIN TNKYTS I
HSCMOOWADOT N ID.ROMPVE
IT
THFTAS W A TERHE DEP OTUARRE
RIODIE EG CIOMIOMSSNEN  ITH
OTSPNG OF7 193TH TO COE UPHA T
FATRDY SKANARE FID BANEGHE TIR
AF.IR
'SEIFRDAXT E MRA LITARALSISIAON
SWE
RE.EREVAL
ATWUMTERO NOUERS ANOSI D CRDSE
ERALARUT O ENDERLI AEVUT P S
CA
YHEEEUS IUL SHOTPOD INUT O T
RWREWE NEAREHE NETH NOFBEUMR
HEEUS HNDBA.
AS W A CNMPHAIONDHI PLA.ER
TRSKY'TIRES LASON WEIH ITFR
MEBE
CANO KWNAN TO TAD I EDLK
INOUABT IST  AF MESO ONGE THLETH
CH T BOOTHA E'ERS RASEPA
FADETEAPR TEVODO TT  ISKTROT
NGLDNGCI OGE AAV HGIN A FLI
CHTH
E TITEAPR E TLIS MANF O
TO
OCBER,KYRO TTS'SFF ATHR AIWI
ALATIA BESOMWN KNOO T N
FOAN
D  ARHI WLE IN TME SHEUMR OF
3719S THITEHR TEA THE
GEIA.TRRS Y'MA
HTH
EYHO AAD S SRTIOAREPATN T
THA
ANCUHA EERXCINNGGET LRSTE B
PLORD F,THOM SWIE THHO SYINCKGL
EXEXITIC SNGL UALAGEUA ON
THSKSY'AR PT.
LLISS IRU TI E  NAMOTIN TRYTOG
MSE.OO BKS
ARAS FYINHEATR-UTAW-L PERT  ITH
OSOE MEF THE PNESAG IHI TS
BO
.OK
CIANNGKS  IYITRNGDVND A A
AGOL
D HEOFE  TIT WHHE TIM TE,
IN
HEINRETESTROY,GL TEEKYTS F
'S GTIETNG O.LD
HE
AN'S 5
T IDNYS HIDA A ANDGEE WOO LK
7CKBA 5OE D'TSN SMEEHA T OT.LD
NLRTCEAIFRNOY T OMREP  UHE IT
DO
N'ESLOT OK TTHA. OLD
.
T57
HIUE' HS CTHLEALD OLE DYAN M B
MUY CHS OL H AESNDERISE  V
INFE
ELG TTHA W AAYTHI TSIM TE
GI
BEINNNGN  IE THTELA 1 I0'93ST
TRDURI S TNGHEIOAREPAT
SKOTYAS WTA SNGYI AAT
DACIHAEN 1BO AUTOU2 RRI DWAVEY.
WA
HESG UR DINETHOR SUB TTINAON
SKTR
OT ANDRIECDA DEDID TO
LL
CA AAL HT.
A
ISWERETT PREYER CINTABO AUT
TH
.
E'TH
ERBSANS  AYUTOLEL NO
ENEV
IDT TCEHA TIE DGONOW OUT
HE TY AF TH, EITH AT
WTI
MEE LARN. O
TWH
ENHEDSRI FENTWP HIBE
NEE
Y OTTRSKDAN DEGGOIE B TANO
HASIDINTTERA.
DIV RISAER DDVECOREKYRO TTS
WAHAVIAF ANGN ITIRFA WHIS H
,WI
FE T, TSROKYE THEAGRIARUT SSN
VO
REARTILUONY, T RTSROKYERIVA,
HI
FOSER HHEWHO O AD HGERR AAND
FEGO DR,IE HIG MHTNDEAV E HEDIS
D LIEEF BOR SS LITAN'INSAASSS
HACECHA ANO TO DO. S
F OGDIO SOU FAMYSL JLESS
THEESPD  GJUD STLYERENALSLW AAY
INATREENGE EO PPLTHWIUN A GN I
HHI
D.ANS
SOPE I S HLACUTEEER HAD H FOUND
OUT WE WOULD HAVE HEARD SEOM
FIREWORKS.
WOOTSKY WOULD HAVE HEARFID RE
S.RK
NOFO
R THEDSRI FENPHIWE BET
TR
ANSKOTY ODID EGAI REMDNE
STRO.
ASIT
W WIE DGOKE BHOROHE TEW NS
TTO
ITSROKYUAFEN BRRY19 OF
TH
HATISLD OER SON, HD  DADIEIN
OPE THPANI CSLIRAFC TE A
APNATERIOMOO  TREIS H
W.NDPEIX
WEL ILLYOBPRABEV NERNO KW
INHER LAULFO PYAS WVENV IOL
ARHE T PTF OHE TT OV SIECRET
STIPOCE
HE TYSOO BKSAY OSECOF UR
HOCDIM O.FF
'S
IT NOT CUTARLE BISHA WT LE CAR
ROIS
TADKYTS HSUO  TASS TMEHI
SHE T CE.AS
BYE TRSK OERTHLD CHINREER W
A W NODEDR  OHAIS DEDPEAPAR.
ERUGDAHTIE DD OFAT N-ALUR -
INNONINAIE DOFD UR NATSE CALAU
SIINHE T U.R.SER T.,UBLO
1TH
R TEBY'92S AND OERTH DGHAU
A
EICSUID INER BEDN LIDI IN3 193
D
ANERNO ATHRRAS W ATEESDN I
BUSC TOWT HAETHRO TTS'SKY NEW
S  TWHT ATDNY HEDI'TW  KNO HE
WAHIOTSH WLE T WTSROKYAS I
N
OTXIMECONDTI SVE ALLLI.
FRHEMEILAMY ERMBS OTHF E
Y'OTTRSK T HSADUR EONDAE
LASI
MI.FAR TE
AS
ID DT MOS OSKTRF OTSY'
THLLFOOW
OF AISLLERFT A T WASIO PHEER
TRHRE GATRO TERR.
ADSKOTS Y'RIPAORS GANITIZA HON
BE
CEPA.N PD RAETTEBY S THE
IN
FT,ACLOHE T CONSTSE CEDAFINT
COWAA NEND KVAGIT ST,O S I
BLEINCVAE TTHA HTH DISEAAS W
IN
AC FTDE MURR.
BEGIESINNNG LYCIPEAL IN93 18
SKTR
OTW NOHATOD OR W ARYUTBO
DSTH ND'KVPRS ESN CEEN IXICO
ANHE TEA RORNSO FHI TS ISHE T
ISSP
ANIL CHIVASAR W W UAYERND W
D
AN B HADNEEIN SCEHE TRUM SME OF
.19
D ANNGEASPKIN TH TEAO YRS
FOHA ACOBEMEITEC RRUOUG INGRND
THR ED. NKV
RGAND ALEN GERNC FRASO' FOR
CTLASEESOR FOLSCE RDLE TO
VIYOR MICOEC BESOM A HENAV
,AREEEF RUGS FEM ROTH W
E BEDENDF S OPUE THREOICBL T
HARESU TT I THELUNCDE NDKV
NTGESS OR IF N AOT
AICE
RTALY NLSTYM SERTHPAIZS.
DEUPHESO'EOP BG LDUIIN
NSFEESF  OETHLU BE USHOEND A
IN
BEG IR HIN AARGUDST TSHIIM T
OSMECOSCARI CTIYLLTAMP IOR.NT
THGUE DSARER WE MTLOSGYOY UN
ICAM
ERSANM  FRORKW NEYOIAN, D
AN
BUMEOREW N YK CITY.
FALT SOMRO MINISAPNEOL WREHE
OTHRO TT KYTSISTD HAPUOW DN
ORROS AHENGLO TEA TTEMSRS
WGANIZA.TION
YHET TASHENL OYCE PLA THE WRE
LLA A FLIALNGMO ANGT WHATS TROKY
ATRI.PROTA
OSO
METHF EMS TEATOAM CE ER SVE
AS
SSLEA GRD AE  SNDOM
THLYESULHA TTHER
NOEEA T ITEMSRSTUR T W ONSUTEER
TRCUALT L  TOUT TOE  B OARGUDS
SKY  ABONYDYE. ELS
ITDE
SPE D'SGO GEROSY ETH
SH
HO OTAORGES FUF NDHEIN T TTSROKY
USD EHUSOLO STJU TNRU THE
OTHODEHOLLSUT B AHIFOO R S
G.INTIECON ISTE QUICK SHO
REONHEF THI TS NGIIS DDVECORE
INHIEAESRCNGHE TTHOO BK EER
LWREWE ANNS AYRUOUING F O
NEMOY.
D E ARD UNNDFU R OSUT OMOF YNE
ANEYTH AIN ARESKGAT NORIAAL F
OTFRHI TS,LE PEASON D'T T
TRD Y SKANNDCKBA AOR F ATHND
AAL
LUNROD.
WAL
SOU N HEYORTSOF OET GHA W
T
YO
ORUAY PHEOR F WUYOS EE S IETH
GU TTYUA QLIMEF  OSO OF
DSARHEND A TUI'SRE QTE
U ANSCDAUS WS AL.EL
E REINE G THNTCUDOMER S OGADREIN
ES BTAOKBO T ITHT ISS THE
TH
RATTCTGRERO TKYTS AOU CLD
OR
LDHE TOS MY MOT NEHEOU C
OTTRATACTO THEAI TL.
COTRIMYSK HSLFSE IANON CSTYTL
INLAMPINT ABG OUALE THQUY ITOF
SHI GRDUASND AEC BSEAU OF TS,
BY
BE93 1 H9SE'YEA RLLTIES RIS
GINUA GEDRD.
ST IRYORMPARNTTA POFT HE T
OY,OR TUP SIMRTPO HLFSEND A
ANGSOEHTRD SKOTY ISTI WRI
HE
TH HASON DEGHHR TOUHE T0' 193
PEE RIODF O HLE EISXIE H
ESTAESBLSD HEHIEP RN ATUTIOIN
OFHES WTIT WHIS H ECPITO HIS
USHE T RANSI RIOOLEVUTNND A
SHI MOIEM, RSMYE LIFH BOT
HEBLPUISDN  IEATHE YRL93 1S0'.
TRO I O19N 38 OUTFPE DESTIRAON
BISKOTY AEEGRSO  TITWRAE
PHOGRAY OFTA SHEN,LI T
ISPU
BLR HEISPE CARR,RE PORCEDESS
M
OTOFISPUY BLR,HE HPEAROLRCNSLI.
STTRINYSK FS  TDSHIRYVE
DIL.TEASFU
HE HRA DGSISEE FABT OUNGTAT KI
ATECESN IM UTLTELATYE H D
THASE H H IO  TDOUSBET CA HE
S NE
EDTE PTOROCT HSEIMLFRO FM
TR
OTSKS Y'SSISTH ASIAS'NSO S W
E
OGHA AIT STIUAIS HONE RI WNGTI A
BIOFPHRAY  W M AANRY'SHO TGIN
INHTOAVILIM H KRYD LEVE
INRETESTG.
TARTRSKETS F TO ASTAS FT
T WI T BHEHYGRIOAP 1N I8.93
NOWURKE THWOESEC BOM BGED D
KYTSSINPRURIS WGLYNHERO T
S ACREHERTE THPAF OHE TTO SRY
EACRSTALIN T AND FTSROKY
SHOFINIE SOVIARUT SSER AFT91 17.
CHEUS JTAN C'TTE WRIS THI
HE.TEAPRS
SEET GS OURISRSRI WTELO BCK
ALAN
D SO HLT HISEANSBEH GIO T
E .
TH OTURERNAF  MOUTEYSRI
S
ESIL
LNTHS AT PGULAED HIM
IT
CROMALIC MN TSEN IE THRUSTLEGG
, FOINWEPOR HE TS92 10'
TRTHLEARIG HHLO BODURRE PSSE
LOSSE,ELEMY OD BGHLORE P
EREV,  OAPTEPETINO, T THE F
TH FHAEREV TACCHT AR HRITEZEIS
ESIL
LNINS 92HE T 1ESS 0'DO NOT
RE
TURN TREHIAD TSNT EEIR
NDSI TIOATN,SS PHEREEUROR F
PUFU TS,HEHEA HLTON CRNCES,
ISBLTER HELIGERYRA A ONTN HIS
TKBATH,  IATS T WHEFSTOR O I
COBESMECT ALLUAY WSE INHE
FA
LL O W19F 38EN HETHENRIDSPHI
EEBE
TWSKTRN OTANY DGO DIE
NSBE
GI.
IDW NOTHOTAS H NONGHI T DOIT WH
THFRALO KAHWA AYN  IRKW NEYO A
K.OR PENARINXC EIT HGER W
THIS TS IE THEIM C SHEESOMNT IO
AD HAS AN ASHISRTT E
UBE
ADSHOWHUHEP R S ANSBD'
LUN
TIS THIE. TIM
SH
WOULRA TCK P HISE SERENCIN
COME
ERREXI FIN HORAVCAHEG R
.FFA O
IRIN
SPIOATNO T AAI PNT SNDO ON.
TSOTSRO IKYS AAY W.
TH WPLT HAEXNSAI TAK BHERE
KYTSSRI FENPHIET BROENWE T
BEDIE DGOMS SEETHRO FM E
YOG NNGIIN TSTDUINO GOOU SR.
OTUE HAV OONTHN E E HDAN
ANTRIGY,SK R,IDCK PRI,LYUL ANGAR
CKTHALD L ROTE HE DGOIE,
RERISSLE, T,GHGA GARUANTN, A
NDONLI AHE TLE EANPHT.
DI
SERLO EGDARET  IIRLAGU
ESDESAR CELYSL,EL SEM DOAR
TRIARVEN OE  TIMRFO AG.THNYIN
SKOTYEA MHINW A WLEASCK STIRLE
ROOTN NEAEGS,ES RNDENIM A
BOINUTE.
HI H MTHENME TADREOUNDSOR WK
WAETCSIE DEL'SGO S DFINCIISPL
INNTGES RTRD TETOAIIS H P
WIAN
D ANHERU ATH BSH IN H
EDTE
NDO T LEOS TCKRAF  OAE
LY
ERHIYTNGE. ELS
HEON
T DAYTH OF ED, DEA
EGNONDERMB 2YTO, DA 1 AND893
UDDIEDWAO LKNT IO T'STSROKY
ST OYTHF E BUSE LUHOANE D
ENPR
ES HTEDIMIT WH S AARUG
SC
NOLHO,UN AOTN  TUAUSLONGHI T
N DO
OETHF AY D OE THADDE.
DLEHAD HHE TAM NETA SELN LISP
TRT OUACSS THEOR FEAEHD.
SKY S A NOTSEMUDSND A A
ASO
ONSHA HE DT  LEFHOTHE E USHE
REOR
DEASHID S TSTSIANO TE HAV
E
THFF O ODIENNGECBJTES D.OYTRED
A YREA I AGOCU SPEROTELA TKYTS
T MIGHVEHAET LT  THA BGOUT A
OIISTH P HNTE H BADOMECSOE  ORTF
FE
UDP.
ETAS WLL ANR UELAVG.IN
THPL SIT CEAM TTHA WWHTEINR EN
POEGDIO  ONTFFEAHE T RL
XILLTILICAINY DV AANCE OF
EYME'SCORE PDESIELIANTL S.TIECON
HE TILL KE PCELAIL UNT
ERSU
MMF  OHE4019 T IRES A
N-GR
OWY  TUPHE RNNCAOTIN AUNGA
D
WEANRE TSOHE SS I AEUGTRGLOR F
POR.
ODI
EGASN'AROTSIST AND
EN
EVARIS H MASSMXI WPE ON T
O
TIQU
ES
.ON
F IGDIO RE AS FITSPE IR
NGYTANHISE  HWA AISOP PULT.
POGIN DGO'SY  VER ABLPUIC
TSROKYICAANRE FELNG T
EDCA
LLT IIG ZG,GGZAINKYRO TTS
LT
VENOHAE D EHO CICOUT B TOV ME
T
VEUF O T HOUSE ANDNEN  IA
AN F WLOAS FNDOU AEWLO BSCKWA AY
SKTRD OTD MOY VEMA IINN Y OF
39.
AEGDIOTS TNDROKYOU WER NLDEV
AME
ETIN.
T
ATINS HIPOHEINT  TRY STO,
ANOTR OFHE THRIG B TEE MEXANIC
RALI INTEREST THY.STE OR
Y OTTRSKDHAEF B ARIERND A VY
THH ETULGINNGEE MTI WIT
ROT
HERE GATANEX MICISUR MALT
TR
WEWASKOTY IMMEATELACINY  F
ISITID D WH. HIM
RETHAS WHE TSTAT LE TEARR OF THE
THT GRE EASTRAMULILYPAS RT
MMUSE  WHEAS SOVI HEAO ILYNT
CO PISUNTS.ITOLIC
K  THEOOIT VER SERIOUSLY.
EGT AS WN'AIL DETTAKEE NTLI
O.DI
HE
OND AN WTETHIN TOTHO  DWIOT N
E LYOM C PNIMUSTS ITOLICT BUIN
30THDYBO'S POLICS  TBYHE
19.'S
IN
FTACSE  HWA'SIE DGOES NEM.IS
THE
RE 2HE4 00FIIDFRA  ILMS
QU
EIT AEURCCAT.
ITH
ESBUHEINWIS NDY STG OR
GOFF OO  TGHFITN IPA SIN
.
THATHO SLLD ULTE A L AOTISUTBO H
CO
NTME.M
S IT
IT'IDSA I VSYER HDARO T
THTEDERMSUFOE R UT B IT SDAI
HATEOM CNDMAED BGARIDE AND
THENIOIV DISOFN HE TEP RLIUBCAN
MYARN I SINPA H ANDATTAED
RATH
E  ONKF LANUTIEENNECOT LO
AN
WAD S IN HPA SINISE  LELIKY
RE
UICRD TE TBYHE NKVD.
R AF
TETUS HIRERN TO MINICEXO
K ORONY,93 19,E  HGABEN W
ON
E OHIF MOS STTAMP IORNT
MI
.LSANE
MEIT ITHN STE LRWAIEL OFHE T
CAXINTE OBSICTRNSIANI UT,
WEERSTL
I  TNTOEE SENT  IWH WAS
ITSEREARGIN THEOO BK.
A'SAN FSTTANG TICHI.
.TR PORT AI TOFHEOUIEEORGIS
'SIT NHIOT LNGEIKT I SNDOUS, IT
RE VISIOPIND A E
NELYAL OTH OF EAS MCERPTEIE
S
HEOF
T93 1S0' MALUR. ART
T
SOS HISWA A MORAJCT AIVITY FOR
HOHI
A VEWE HR,E WO AASLSOL INVD VEIN
ENFFDIER OKIT NDVIACF TI OTYN
E
E.IDS
ISTH ONENS SPOOREDY  BETHKV ND.
MMHEASNL EDTE TOEA LD ANRM AED
THCODOAND  RAIONRO TKYTS'SOM H
BEIS TK PLEN I THEOU HRS
4 AWREFO DH WHN ICISBOUT
0.9420. O 2 MAY4, 1
MEN DSSREEDLIN  IPOCE AND
LI
MIRYTANI URMFOS AEDRMIT WH
MA
HECHINE GS,UNAC SADOSAR HN O T
ORUN
AJ M.FOFM N  AARMY
TH
E MER EANNTED THE G.UNRODS
DIHO
W Y TDHE GET IN?
TSNWA'T WTSROKY GLEL?RDUAED
WNE OFMEHE T AGUCARIN DSARM FRO
THEHAOR YK DEE BNEC R BITRUED
O ND.KV
E.ATNEPED THE G
ON
CE IN ILA PCEENSIDHE T
TYCO
URDAR, TMA CHEOMOSND, THE
P URINUDSES TELHE TMSSVE
TS
OU TE IDOF'STSROKY THEMUR DHA
DOD ANWI TROKYTS G'SRDUAS PNE
IWNNIR THEUA QBYERRTS
A-CHMAINIRNGU FHEASE  TASN  OLE
AR BFGERA OAC MUNNEHI-GE FIR
HETOIN T T'STSROKYRO BEDM FOMRO
THETIIR DECS.ON
ONOMROS IT EDER HESI ANDHE
IDOU
TSOWWIE ND.
HE
HO CLS AORIARED WH TH THREE
BMAMEDEBSOM,NL OY ONE O
ADWHWEH NT IFF OOMA N RO
TCEJANTTHO EED BRO.OM
E CLY RLEYTH WEREIN TRYETTOG  S
THONACPLE E. FIR
BEEYTH LTER AFT5 1 MUTES
OTSIEANG THE H DADONE THEOB J.
FAN CTSKSTMU B IDEE AD
TH
YSKY HADAI FD LE MTOT EEOTTR
UR HT.WALATIATE ERNO
TH
EYDUC DKEANOW DN DVI SURVEO. T
ISOTY'SRA COMSDE CLEALD TH
TH
THAMEOUACIRULESS  APECAS, TND
TUEOEIT TTH OLEF OGPRE OL
TH
EK BOO BAUECSE IAN BEGIT WH
ATH
ISACTTKRA DMATIC AD ACTTKEON
THY MA2494 10.
C NOMECOTHS TIFRE AN
ANIOARATTHFON R EEX NTAC ATT
THAND  THENT AATICIP TN IOIS
IT
IL WLE BIT WH.OM BBS
EDRMUSLMFI MBET FORA TNS
S.ES ATR FOR
TOTOUSCEEN MBET  CSTONCTRUEDN O
TH OPF HIE GH WDOLSAL, LEUB
HEIR DRSOOUS MTCEEP RLA T
ODWO EENRANTE NCTO THE GAGARE.
SHEESTL TEUTT  MRSUSVECORHE T
NDWIS.OW
BOMBPRF OORRWAR IOGTTNEINUS MT
BE
STD AI RSEDAN BEBWARIR BSRIARER
MUVEE  BMOD IONTOS PIOITN.
BU
T ENVE AES OS
RTFOICIFSIOATN' TEG BANOIS REP U
T ORTOND DIDEC TEDOES R
IT
THSLB FALANK ACPL
GNASE SIFNTME OIQ LNGDAUITI
SKTR
COS ME T AY,NDER OHERD
CTDI
INML.EM FLYRO THERE K
ATH
ATENIGSSNMT WELDOU B
REIN
TEEDSTO T AN LOATIPE ORA
.VE
ADEYTH HEDAN MAGO TET PENTERA
TRSKSY'NN IERIR CE.CL
A R WASONAMTECC MOTR,
RDANSPIA RRUECEDITY BHE T SCEPA
IN SINPAUR DG INANE THSPHIS
L CI
VIR.WA
DIAR P IISTHN E SMEUMR19 OF 38
D UISGSEAS AEL BTUANGI SNTDE
INUSGHE AASLI HE S BUCEDEDAY
KYTS'SON OF OFE RO
ERFO
RM SRIREECTARM, ESFOER
SHSTTSAN
E WAE S AOK BRONLYRO TTSKYT IS--
SHSWAIS VINITG -AR PIS-
DIBITTNOOVI SYLA.
RKMCENERTT MRID ARARDVEWN  INE
USYOE N  ITHLLFA OF93 19OW N
AE G INTHMENANK FRA J,KSACON
.ANACADI BSMINUSES
TH
SIAT WAS HISEW NITDE INT
F IALV OWNEBO AUTS  THIAS A
ONFRANT DED DECID TGOO NG ALO
SHTHWI IRFO O HERWN R.SOEANS
NHAE DOWHDE IA  W SATHEAS UP
O TO
NEEAID HGEEL BONTOD HE T
VD
NK.
XIAN MVEEURED LVSYN  DIAOWTO
CIMECOIT CDY AND USEER HO T
INRANE HTE ISEIMLFONT
.TTRY'SKS HSEOULDHO
HE
EA HVYEDIM TOE  BA
FI
NCNAL IATEPPSUOROFR HE T
TENFRCHISTSROKYT I PNARIS.
4019 C TE RSBYHEUM SRMEF  O
ERERTHEAYNOS  WO TIF VER TS,HI
TH WS E'NOCO TAYO ACNTT THE
CHFRENTS TROBEISKYT THUSCAE EY
TE ARON RHEUNRO F TMHENV IINADG
S.RMAN
THOUE RETB OAKFHE TOR WLDAR W
ICWHLYREH ALTA SS,RTWA IT MAS DE
PASSPOIBY BHE T NISAZ SIEOVT
CTF O AUSUGT,9  193RUSTCK A
GBI BLOW T AIAGNSY OTTRSKDAN HIS
.TYLFOOWS INEW NCIOR YK
METIITRKYO CBEY G INATS  THI
ALONNRTE OTHF E ITIERNTNA
CETRYSK MT.EMOVEN
T AIRTSNY NLWA T'TPAO SRI
ALISTH P.NT
MOOUGH SEEHE TREN CTE OFHE T
HIETNGVENTS TNDHIS IOM S
EL
MBSEUI QINHO SCKG T THEALOT
ISNUTR OERF S SKOTY'IN THE. U.S
00BLRO PBAR NEY VEREMOHA TN
TH2,
D PEYAI THEIR MEMBERS
.
WH
EN T WHEAR BKEROUT O TTSROKY
OIINEDSTIS HOL FLO TWERS
SU
ORPPTHT EOV STIENI U DONPIESTE
ETHAC FTHT  TATHE SLITAREN MEGI
WIOUPED  HT FISILAMY AND
CO
ADMR AESND OCOF SEUR WAS
YITR TNGHAO VE TROTSLE KKYIL
TROTY SKTRIEDO TUS JTIFYHE T
RNTEET OUPCCATION OFAS E
ALAPONDSUA S RE OLTFHE TAC PT.
TH
F OTI BALE , CSTHONVAINSI
39LFIANTH IN ERWIE NTAR WF O
MY19O T W 40,CHHIAV GE THE RED
TRAROD B ALO SNOY SEOO T SPE.AK
BUSASKOTY MA WIDE Y NOTIK LE,
SPT T A RHEEDYRM IACINS  FT
THGADREINLIOC SIASM.
WEE FACNIST  I THETOV SIENI U
ITAV HE A WOR SRSKE'TETA.
TETAIS EREG DENOREDAT WRKE S
Y OTTRSK ILLCAEDBUT T
THNO
NEESELTHS ETA S, TEERTHISE
E ST
ATNEOW OHIRSPFEAHE T M ONSF
ODPRUCTI AONTH SNDO PIOCE CUED
TE
NGTIITRRORSRE AET G
ACISOALHEATM  TND EF O
NEBA
YOSOT  TO SAKPE WITTHE RED
MY
IOARNG BRI FG ININEM ROTH SIEOVT
N.UN
SETIVES RYUSUR CIOEC B
SITHER VYE TIM TTSKYAS W
INNGGOR WSTRSKE' EAT
ATTEUTNERKD TEWOTAS'ER S
AS W TAM SE TEIMKYRO TTS
VE
NLIYPE OALYNL CHENGLI TTA S
THREME TARALOTITNIAND A WTHA IS
ROTE HEAL TOTN ARITIA?GIREME
.NYA GZIER
IMOR FIS HOLLORSN  IRKW NEYO
NFPROERWE  WNOREHE'S L AOT OF
ETHOTHIOUSN 'T CEYANW OL FLO
HE TM.MNO, TFLL A O
ON
IKYSTHINELI ATS TNDRO
STIN
SIDT ENANISHI TS GAK TINP
AL
TITHL E E, METHGR BIO OHYAP
F
AR WSTINS ONOL HD,HE WLD
RE
THADLYAL EATF  OWHO T W DO,
IEOVTOTIO TE TAKTH ON E S
N UN
OFN IODANHE TIONV IAS
D NLFIANDANO STH ON EN AAT CR
ST
THEAG NOW
TEDEE BAMO ANGHE T AMECAN
THOTTRSKS ST TADLESO A.PL SIT
TY PEARS I EMA SLLUGNOBUH
T
TH
ETHERS I AOR ST E ROFULF  O
SRTPAIE ONHE T TEF LTT HAIFHE TY
SAR
LISPTHELLMA TUG OHTO  T
IN
TOEC BEOM S.LLMAER
D
ERNISHI TS HA WTAP HNSPE. NOW
F OH IES AAJ MFOITORY THOS
UYOHO W KW NOURYOANUS RSI
ST
HIADY ORREEVOL BSHECSIK BSEAU
TTHS I ALL TITTSROKYEER REFDRE
TO G THEWOUPROS.
TH
THY MYORAJIT SINPOUPRTGTS TRO
ALEAGHOU RAKY LLSHYT A TESIM,
ICPEESCILY FFT AERLAINND AND
ANWHHEG BS ININBEEC DEM9 1R,93
VID LES ADTO EONULXPSIEF  OTH
SOETNI UONRO FLETHM E UEAGF O
S.TINAON
CHOR MINY,ITALAP CIT., M WTAN
GRTODEONMNOVHE T ST IERYLIMITA
E AGSIESONLL A RNDHTIG AO D MY
STTHR.S.U.S. WAS W A'KEORRS
EER ATOF AD  KNYINDAN TY W
TRVENG AH WRYITNLOT N OY
SKOTSY' PNITOSIOHEUT B TAY W
SI A IUERGDT.
TOBA CLLCAYNGPAOMRIHE TITIN MOR
EMLDHE T OSH MENIKEVSNGAL CLI
RSNE BET PTYISRGOUEOAIOM CPL
OUDAN S W AONNDN HETHEY GOTAD
WHNREDHT AT CLIALNG HIM E
T H ICGOALL REAY. MAD
SY
O IALV, THEROOKNTS TROT,KYIS
WH THEAT C'SAW PN I THE
Y ST
ORHEOKTO TOFID SE HE T
NO
MINDTYRI AHE WNHE SOOT G T
XIMECOY, CITHE SAS IITEDO T
D ADETETOOM CE RO TKYTSSE H'SOU
ARANBADETEHIIT WH ANM D THE
THGU IDSNKYRO TTS'S.TU SDY
WH IISS RME ERHOEON AND -
-
.NGOMONAAWIS HNI OPE
ASHE WPO S AUPERRT OFROTS
MAN
DY.ORAJIT
S
LIHEY VAWER LTLITTABE OU
CSTI.
HE
AS WER VY A AWAWKRDTUTBO IND A
LDSH
D ANITAV HEEE BR CLN EA
WA
UNRODARORY EVEEON A
SKTR
OTONY HE TES LTHS  WEYTEN
ON
E ALWIG TH IT.
TH WRTCAERN TERO IT DRA AFOF
AN A DICRTLEENEFHENGDI T
MAJOTYRIIOOS PITANN DHA HE ITD
Y RE
ADINUG AUS0  1T,94DANSK AED
OT
MTRY TO RDEA IT.
HEREEUANVE TOAL BE EONH WIT
SKTR
OTJUY STWOHE T TEMF  OTH
N I
TH
AUE LATER AEFTFONNO O
ER WETGU 2HEASH  TSUA GRD
ENSYNSG LLTAINAEW N HIR SENAD
INBEVEEC REID FM ROTHADCOE MRES
COOS LEL ANG.ES
WAMCERTT, WTS THOROUM AKYSS
E A CADIAN BINUS BSMESANY
MENHFMENA ORA FKS JNKAC
SOOE ONWHTHYM SPAEDIZ WHIT THE
OFCAE A A WNDASTIOT PENAL SRCOU
RTEC MEDNEH-EDDS FUNOT MCC
T ANE D RETH WUDSTYMH ITHI
OUABT:3 50T THA AFT ONOERONF
2GUAUST0CA OF  HYIRRNGISRE THNC
ATCO.
DEIN
SIOAHE T CWAT SR,AG DGE
ND
HANGUND A P NKAICX, AOTIC NE
KAICX. P
PIEASND A WOI PIKEDNT LANE  ICE
E, CKTH OERTHLAAS W FANT D
.WI
DE
E
HNGADN HDLOUABT 1LOOO FT
BE
TR D CENUTN OWRFOCE CONINALG.
ONSKOTY AND HISSISS AASN ALL
AL T AE,NDT  RHEESTO UISP
U.YO
PPANKOU Y.
USLAE]
OUIF
YE HAVST QUENS,  HE
WO
GHDUL S TP TEUPMITHO E NEOPCRHO
QURITVER RE AHA WNDE VE A
TIESON.
A THIS IA S NGLO LOOK FOR
QUESTIONT HAIT'S WORTHHE T.
I'MUR CUSIOBO AUTTALIN'S ROLE
AOU YNG MAN AND FINANCING- -
NCAOU YEA HR TS?HI
DITSNOE'T SOUND ATHS GHOU IT'S
ON
.
>>CAE N ALL HREAOU Y.
SI>>'M CURIOUSBO AUTTA SN'LI
IARGS A YOUNG MANN IEO G
D GAENGE O AINLLTHF IS CMIRINAL
TYACVI, THEY A BOMNGBI OIL
FIELDS ANDOB RNGBI BANKS AND THE
NSA THAT.
IF
HEAS WIN FANCING TROTSKY'S
ETHLE OR EXTEISNCE PRIORO  T
NSSRUIA ROLEVUTION.
>>
ERHE WTHNTA SLICEIN FAND
SKTR
OTISS Y'EXNCTEERI P TORO THE
RUSSIAN REVOLUTION?
>> I'VE WRITTEN BIOGRHIAP THA
ALST FINANIND CENELIPRN RIOO T
E THVORETILUON, DAN IRON WDEF I
MOTH
E YNESE  HWAATEN GERGIN
TH
T HIUGROH RINES FASOUITCT AIVSIE
BUSOALPO SUPGINRO TKYTS.
ITESTI QUEANIOSTN MUD CH
EERRBONTE A IUTTEC RTHTLENY
IS AAPIO BGR OHYF C ALALOU YNG
INST
ALMOY  BSIEMON NTOR FAY R
LLKSATAL AUTBO T SHIS,
OVNTCOROLLY RSWIERHE WTHHI TISS
.DOERNE
TROTYRR-  -SOTA AY,USLND A'S
RO
LE IBAN  RNKBEOBESRIEEF BOR
E
THAR W R BBIOBNGN KSAN IRORDE
STO
BPOUPRTIKSHOLEV ORATIS.
WI
THOUTHTOR STF  OITWATOG ININ
GM QATUACAE IRI N TLEL YOU
OTTRY SKWASN A'TOL BEVSHIKIL UNT
1719.
E NSOOTNDNVE IY ECIRTLS WE
EDFU
NDY BHA TT.
F
INT T ACLEMEAY SKYRO TTSAS W
AN
AAR ELY OLYCOTEFAN LD --
LE
TONNI W BUTN HEETHTY PAR SPLIT
INEVOL BSHDS IKANEN MIKSHEVS
NGATON C TESGRS,ON SHEEC
TRCOF SSRE ORTE THPAY IN90 1
OFSKOTYN  I OE THUPN T SIDE
HHEN MEVSHS.IK
IMIFEHEER WE WO HREE DUL
DNELDIMEATYUT BN I S AND I BAYUT
N IIY S'TTATHIT WH NDEM A
SFA
CTHEKE BROH  WITETH
NS
ME AVIHEKSSL. WEL
IROTTRSKAL TKUT ABORE FE
OFD  HS,ITASE W AIN K
LAFR
EEE NCORLLS  AWEN IY V AER
SE
.AYURIS W
ARUACHE T FIST  FORLLF O THO
YESRO F U19M 03P TO91 1
TRSKOTYAS WNE OF O LEN'SINAL VOC
ICCR
IT
S.
O AINLLETHF OS CTICIS WLDOU
NIMECO BTOK  HNTAUTS TROER AKYFT
D LEOMBYN  S19E 24 ATAND SNLI
WAANETHTH OS ER SOUARND WLITAN
YSKTNTO MEAK SOTE URTR
N'DO
ESEESUT CCDIN LENSE  DU.
OS
TRTHQUE SOESOT, N I AAY W
SKS Y INTHE BIKSHOLEV
THRTPAY  R A17NDSLIEAZET IS I
NLE OSHY OWN I TN.OW
HE'SHE TRE GTO OATRAOFR  T
N.SRUIA RIOOLEVUT
IHE
'S TFAN CTHE MINTEASRMDF O
TH
OCE BETOCOUPFTA IOU Y
WI
L,IL LLANLLOT N A OYOU W
THBU
T COE UPE DAH TA OF 17 91SO
LS BHEECER AES VRTIMY POANT
OUAOVIHEKUT BRO TEMKYTS RNSAI
D  WIDTSERTHHIITN E.AR PTY
ANHENOAD H EHUGHI IN S
ALCKBAGR ENDNOHUGICOL PIT
AGBA
GGSOE HA THIT SEN MONTIED
ME
AGSO ISLW AAGS AYDRTD GEOU
HINSAIT HEANM D OU WLD ALWS
Y SAI DT IDN' TLOBENGTHO E
WANSMEHE N BKSUTETHESS I
NT AEVOLIBSHMIS.
ROT
HE QUE?IOSTNS
ODAN
PUTEP? SWAY NT
WHE
REEE  HAVREE ONHE
AN
EIFD  HOULDSE UHE T
OPMI
MALENRITNEHO WNTA H GE
NGCO
LLUAYI A HUNRODCTEER A
TMI
T.ENH W TANTWAO IT AOM M
REHE WE GO.
>> JUSSOT RT OF CONTINUINGIT WH
THE SUGTRGLE BETWN EEALSTINND A
OTTRSKY AND THE DEVOPELMENTS
FR
TOM THEEIMF OHE TUS RSIAN
IICIWAL ANR THALD L K  WEOR
HAVEN'TE EATHBOOK
FFSUIEICNTLYET Y OR MUCH OF
TR
OTSKS Y'DIRING.
TBYHE END OF SHIIF LWHE ENE H
WAINS XI ELE IMEN XICOOR FHE TSE
ARYES -TH- IS MICPHONEEE NDS
--
I WILL REPEATHE TUE QIOSTN.
TRHA WT OPINION IFAVNY A HE
IS H CYSKOEOM T RNGAREGDI
E?GLDEATN T IHELERNTNAUG STR
DIHO
ELMSF ED HXP ETINLA IHI TO
WHAN
D SO LATESNSE ID D HAW
FR
OM TT?HA
HO>>YER GD QSTIO
HINISS TIDROKYLA EXP
ATDE
ID DFEALO  TSTN, WLHEOW H
INUYO RZENAIOLIT? I
OF TARFREDS HIEN AIS CARALTR P
MYOO B WK,THA RLLEAY BOTREHED
SKTR
OTHEISY  TOB'SRE NALY ODSTIN
FEDEEDATIM HST, INALAS W THE
BL
HEUR 1N I7.91
THT AS WN'E ONOFHE T OTA SRS
.TYOL BEVSHIKAR P
T YEOLSTN LEETPRTYANDI
TDEEDATKYRO TTSEN  ITH92 1S.0'
WEOUK ALABTFL CONT.IC
LYREAL WHE TREAS NOON CFLICT.
HE
WT ENWNDOY  VERY ICQUKLIN
RTPAEC B TAUSETSRO WKY AASOO PR
TIPO
LIANCI.
AL
ST WINAS A VLEY ERAB
TIPO
LIANCI.
D
STNLS AO T'STSROKYNTEVIBSHIK
PA IHI WCHOL TD A YOU ABOUTND
POHEOTR LTILICAA  IDEAT T
ICA
LLWEUESSS UG BREROHT IN.
TH
WEOSE  TRE BHEIG OS.NE
BU
ALT T FOR, TSROKYIDTHE EA THAT
THSTE , INTHANORGEGIYO, UNOW,
ESA PEAIA, NTASCTIAS ERNTEY B
DE
OFFEATED THERE GAT TTSROE, KYON
REREHE T GDE LATEARSF  OETH
ONLUVOTIY EA RLLVIOBSLOUY
GGBUED. HIM
THAN
D F BRE IEHEXP EINLAED AT
WA
ALSAS NGYIHA TSTT INALAS W
PRREOD NLYOBLSTY ILUT BE H
REENTEAUR BCYUCEARAT THA
SSVEHA ELYTIENAL TENAKTHVE OR E
SORGETVI O WISANMSEER CDTUAPRE
BR, ITA EROKT ATRATN TTHA
HIHA
D  TCKJAEDOL RHEEVANIOUTN
THSTL ILAOR WSTRSKE' EATUT B
ISEA BURC RAUCTIWAASCLS S A
RERAPASICNT EY ITATTHAD HO  TBE
SOVEMOD.
ROOR F TEKYTS HN' WAST
EDFEDEATY  BA PSOERN.
N.S  AAYHADTEHE TIOUE QST
DIHO
W  YDOU LEOSER POW
HE
OUEHE T QANIOSTN ASID  W
D AS
IM TE.EL ALTH
HE WLDSOEE MT BOMEDY OTHN E
S  IATETYDOANML ARE TNDHE
TESE
KEURYIES DGIBCRIN T
BOSO
KYTSMES 'SDY IETH GROATRE T
AN
E HYG BODARRDUAS E THE ERDAN
EKSHESD, HANOW D YOUOS L
PO
R.WE
DITE A IT-  - DHEID ITHOIK LE W
YDOUOS L WYOE URLET AEND H
THA
DOIC BASAYLYAL SND AE H
TAULWOD  YLKR OUARYETFF O I
SNWA'TBO AUTN TA SLIETH
VIIN
DIITALDU, ASBO A TUTHE
IM
ALRSPEONSOR FCE OFTO HIS.RY
CHMU ETOIEASR WIEA DL  ITHT
ATRSPEONLYU F  IYOBESCDERIT
QUTHAY W.
TIESON RHTIG HEER.
VEONT  AAR SSTCAICOT NE,OU Y
HA THEUS RANSI ROLEVIOUTNAN, D
ENTHOU YAV HE THE BALETTET BWEEN
STALINND A TTSRO.KY
MIALIN TESAKOW P AERND KIL
IOLL ANS MNDLIILSON OF PEOPLE,
RIGHT?
OK
.AY
WAS ALL TS HIWORTH REVOLUTIO
WHY NOT JUST SCKTI WITH THE
RUSSIANST ARIRAOCCY
HI TS?DUS RA SIGOGHHR TOU
ISAN
D TN' AYP TICALF ORYIS HTO
TH
STS TATHIOFYP TE HI TNGAP HNSPE?
JUOPOU YR IOINN?
EST>>HAS IEON OFHO TSE BIG
ONTIS.
ACI'
M  TALTULYG CHEAINSECOA UR
IN THETA SHIORNFD ORSTY
ANA DERTDE, NTMOSI RRNUS
ITH
IS OSOS RT TLIF KEHEHE TME
LOAKAE T CNDE,RS A WOU T
E  TNGIMWE ATONSRHE
QU
ONTI.
TH
EVE FTACS IKYRO TTSS LW AAYIDSA
NGYTERHIAS WTH IHR TGHOU
OCTH
E BER VOLUNDONTI A F AEW
YE
HASAR BEYDD ONAN TTLL Y
ACDO  T WDOASO TTHUS OT PAE IR
THICIDE EG RIM WD ANHEAVLDOU H
RESONRATOTIFOC DEMCYRA,
ERWO
RKCRDES MOD Y ACANHUT
VI
SOOC DETEMCYRA.
INAC FTRO TKYTSBL P'SRO IS
'TWA
SNPO P ARONT ODECRMOYAC
HILWHES E WAIN TIE SHEOVT
ONADLEER.IP
TEEADY WN HEHEASEI BNGEF D
DI
OFED NIEC ROG V TZEHETUIRE
ITH
EERNN PEMTYAR D ARAOCCY HNDE
BE'T TKIALNGBO AOC DUTEMCYRA
HANDYO T
D
RSNN IAC FT,F  IUYOHEET G T
FIRIT TESS ALTHEOTRE A NHE T
SH
TOWALRIS BAL TUTRIAN BSEG IN
30, .9,
T A
LO POFPLEOE D'TONNO KWBO AUT
THTHE.
N AEYRE TOTAL THERISF  OETH
ECLSBOHEERLEK ADS BUTNG E,EEINRS
OFS LIIASTSNAR VUSIOLD FIE
OSH MIKSHENEV19S 31 AND FOR
INGH TEALRIS, TTSROKYS IIV L
AB
EDADRON  IRKTUEY ARTUP SPO
SWI
THISLITAN OI DNGCIRI CTING
INST
ALER LATULE  HWOAPD IZOLOGE
R
AD H AHIUT BKYRO TTS
IBCR
EDPRITILY ANLEOBM HED E CAM
TO
TRA B Q ATEUO ONUO QOC DTEEM
ATD ANTHS IOR SOFT AR PHEOFT  T
ICRGLAERSTUEIOUN YO AIN ARESKG
WHORISH  MOFE  AHE RLRITOCA
LOESQUTIITHA TT OU WE  TLDAK
HEE TIMO TWE ANSR.
S,OTTIQUR ESS?ON
YE SIR.
>>EAV THE ARCHIVES AFTER THE
DIFA OF ETHTOV SIENI UED AONDD
ORAD OONTIALMA FNEORON OYO
YSTY --IT ADD INAIOLTIORNFMAON
WHONORR OUST
AAT WLD BINTHE E ARMECO PT OF
XIITNDHE TIC MEXE, SANID AS
MESIN CARENTDES?
E  FE QOO GDN.STUEIO
ENTHONESQUTIETS  IWHRHEHE T
OP UGINPF  OETHRC A TVEHIS,HE
IVCHESERARIEOVT
UEIN
FLEDNC M, BOY OKDAN IL WIL
EN
HEOPNEN  IGEANLLRAY DAL TTABK OU
OTROL SCH.SHARIP
A SRTHO VSIERONS  IHEENWH T
VISOETNI UONOL CLAPSESND A BIS
YE
ASILT BNOMECREES PDESIRE TNTHE
NDISDER PIOOT N TO GO BA ACK
SA
BUYYEHA TT SILTNER WE ILLIC
E THT ERSWA AIO PERDHE WN W
E
EA MNA AHE WNAY I SE W I
SRWESTNEA RES AHERCRS AWES LL
RU
IASS HN,E AVLOA TF O ATOESCCS
SOHOV STIERC AVEHISNC IDILU
THMEKV ND, KGB AS.HIRCVE
EYAD H ATHESCCS  C HATASE OMTO
TIANNDCE SINSCHE T AYDAENNCF O
.NPU
PLAPYEN DTTNEO  TY EAGRTLOMFR
E ACSSHA TT WASIV GENXNF ILU
Y
SAETH FSTIRIG EHTRS YEAF  OETH
'S90 OFITHR E TRSEAER ARSFT
E
BEHL  FAL TOFHE SOVTIENI UON
CA WEUSTHAAP HNEPED ISHE WN
U
SYO DN'IDHAT VEES WRNTEARCH SOL
G GO
INTOINHE TRC AVEHIS,HI WCH
RE
IS MINMAEDCLTLOSY UREDOS DGIN
SCUSAN PERD,ADOU Y H R
RULAHORS ANDS TH OEREDTAATCK
ANSSENN IAAGESCI,HE TSI RUS
SU
BLESCCRSOTH TO E I KGBELTSF
PUHIIS BNGKSOO OF DTSUMOCEN
,
ALN HEEREE A IGR IRIMAT TE
CO
AS OMEUT AUTBOHELO PTOT
ATATSSSAINSKTRE OT TY,HE ELIARER
RKANMPTET THD EHO WWO NLEET
MOE THNK T PUTETOGR,HEOW HH MUC
UNY NEEYTHPE SNT ON IT, RHTIGP U
KOOTI W IASIS FINHENGHI T B
WAERTHE SGR B AIOHYAPHA TT
OTCA
NNDJ AUGT USCA T IHTNE TO
FLBE ATOE SE UT I AIO BAPGR OHY
ON
OE K TFHEBE MEYEMRSF  OETH
HE TTQU SADWEHAT NTER AFT
D.AIZENIDHE T COMAOMND R
ERWO
NDLLFUYOR INFTIMAVE
Y.OGBIRA
ESO
WAN C E G'TETECSPLLIATHY E
ST DADBUE TSTH OERID DND I
EVBE
LIOUIFE  YEL BHEVEIE T
RE
MYEWVIS CC ANTOU OF THE
TR
MUSKOTY ERRDS IS THE MTOS
HEARNDTELE TWET AV HE SO F
AEDLPN IAR PTEC B FSEAU INDOU
CHEAGRTERATERLSIA HASE HE T
REARHEESIV WO  IRE D O LAOTMYF
.ARSECH
AL
EEROHE TAR HRCRDVA AWHVEHIS
SHISAP PER ARE.
AL
TRLHESE U TXI ELE PNTOIS.
FOSKOTS Y'INPOHAT VEEE BTHN EER
RYA R VE LIMGON TE.
IN
AC FT HE SD OLS HIPEPARSO T
ARHA
RV BJUD STOREFEE HIE DD ANDC
K
STAU
GU H0  2IFIVREE CEED A
RILETEGRIN SAYG HAPIS PSER ARE
ARFED VESA AT H.VAARRD
,0$600 IST WHAAR HRDVAAI PD ALL
T THWI $0,00UI QZI ATEMA.NG
BUETHLE EXID PAPSCH WHI
ANS ERYVEINTHFRG  1OM992
BR TDTTSROKYAS W EXID LEOMFR
TH
P U SIEOVT UONNILL AAYHE T W
NOTIUNL W HTH DISEAETH, OSER W
T ONPE TLASCO HORSNT U0. 1IL98
DAN BAUSETH OF  OATUT TOLL A
SC
CLAHORSEOM WSA IACTE WHORO
TH
ESS CLAICRI TGYLO HAD AESCCS
TO TTOHOVERC AHIYOTHS E HAU
TIMSTRU H ANDE  GSNWA'TATRE
NDOESOU SRCOT N AAYLW AS,
WH
IDENT IE CAM TO THERFF AAI WH
ANFRE A H TOKLOEDHEER OTH WAY
OUHED  CBEN'LDT ELIEVT I WAS
HEPPHAEN
WASST FLUEDER.
WAE S TN' HLA BME,IM H
RI
T NGDIN  IETH 10'95S.
SOBUETHOY B TRABIO OGDY PHHA
EEME AESSISO  TTH B TUTHE
THSPIOOFD  BAPGRESHIFKYRO TTS
ONNO CATANHEOFT  T 1 N0'97S,
PLEOE HUR OES ACCS SO P
TH
AN KD INOFOS LREINE TESTN I
SKTR
OTYND AHE TNN  WHEEYTH
IGAREINT,ERNTEST ND A IARSTTS
THWITR DMI AI, FMEETSOR VI
GRMYEN GAL WHO WTERISSE THE
T BHIGRIOAPNES IARHE T ELY
19ND'S90 AAS H AESCCS TTHO E
EVARESIVTH, E CO
RV IYOERNEUS FSOC NEDOTN O
N OAHED,AR TARY EOC FUSED
WH YAT'ROUEGSK AINBO AUT
.
ANTANGE TO T IONT A THESHIRCVE
WHD ATE SEWHS  IERTHSOE N  IFACT
ATND F IOUS  AI BOANEG T
AS EHECHAR TOO BKERS  ITHE I
T LOOF GATREFF STURVT  AHADAR
DANHE TNE HERHO WOR FNH IITER
TTHAP PSER OFHA TPAT RTY,HA T
WA
CARI.RO TTS'S PNTYAR IME A
D
SEESDWHELDOUE B SPRUP
BE
R USCAERHOE OVAS H AUT REPIOATN
INFOA INBEG VANSCOERVETI
THTAK-NKHEUT B T AREREAN M
Y
LOPPELEHOTEF WGEIL WL TIR THE
SERS TOHE TROO HVEVERC AHI
BE
TUSCAEOWY HEKNHE TYIL WE B
WE
EN TLLAKE CARWH OF  TENHE
ARRE
SEERCHSE  HAVCEAC ASSNDO S
ON
.
TGR
EA STU, ETH BRDYGODUAS,
SOTE TERSTS,ER PHEAPHEARS E
W I AASE BLTOSE TSE S
TOL ALOFTHAEN TAK TR ETOGHEIUT P
TTHGEERRY SHETOF  ORDE THMUER
IN
A WT  TAYHA BDNHA'TNEEE DON
REBE
FO
ON
E MORST QEUEN.IO
YE
N. OS,NE MUEEOR QIOST
CO
ME ON UP.
I
REIL WL ATPET.
[DIAUE]BL
AEEC DEDID IHI TNK L FGEARLY
HESTC TIRPPUESOS TOVOID
Y OTTRSKICWHH S LNDOUSUE IKYO
GE
T AL CAL WARN HECLPEK ST
ROCO
NT
IT
SOU SNDTL L AITEUN FNYO T
TR
OTSKST WD  UASSEIAND
CIDEDDE TGOO  WH ITTHAT A BNDE
CO
NSISNTTEXC ET EPERWHOTI E QUED
SOPELEGI SINNGRT T, KIOSTE
DSUNES LSUT MLUA.
WOTH
E SO ORDF SDSUN A OLDS AHE T
RU
REIASSN ONLUVOTI B MAYE O
F
WALRELY IN HEHESN  IEXILTHE EER
,TYANME ACARINKYRO TTSEITAR P
MI GJUT STTERASEN  OTH YREA
TOSOE  I DIDECED NOT TO EUS
ATTH.
DKFO TS,NKHAFOS R CINOMOUG T AN
I
LLWIEE SOU YLL A AINGA.
PP[AUSLAE]
ER BANTRPAD NATEEUDS  IETH
AU
ORTH OF T AHERIMEN CALIREEF
PEEXTIDI TON SORUIEOVT IASS IN
AMETH F